this works and a lot of you can be doing
it too obviously these are two iconic
Brands and they're doing cool stuff over
here but the reality is is merchandise
as marketing is a massive opportunity
and collab merchandise is a monster 2
small Brands coming together making a
hat or a hoodie or a t-shirt or a
whistle or a toothbrush or some pancake
batter it's just a good idea it's
conversational it's cross-promoting
communities it's relevant the Press
likes talking about it and whether
you're iconic Fortune 500 brands or
small businesses and creators the collab
especially when merch March as marketing
is a massive theme for the next decade
and way more people need to get on that
train Merchants marketing get on it